welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and this Sunday January 15th is
the premiere of The Last of Us on HBO so
I wanted to make this video to help
flesh out the world for those who have
either never played the games or just
won a refresher and convince you of why
you need to see this show whether you've
played it or not now I have worked
really hard to make sure this is a
completely spoiler-free video so that
everyone can fully enjoy the journey so
please join me in keeping the comments
section spoiler free as well so let's
talk about the world we'll be entering
in the game most of the story takes
place in a post-apocalyptic relatively
modern day Society 20 years after a
devastating infection spread throughout
the world the game only very briefly
touches on what the pre-pandemic world
was like leaving the player to piece
together Clues through discovered notes
letters and recordings however Gabriel
Luna who plays Tommy in the show
disclosed that the show will be living
in that time before and during the
outbreak for much longer than the game
in addition while the game relied on
staying in the perspectives of Joel and
Ellie in order to keep the player
immersed the game's Creator Neil
druckman and the showrunner for the HBO
series Craig Mason said in an interview
that they found a freedom in moving
through time and space in the show
showing things happening before and
during the start of the Apocalypse as
well as outside of America while leaving
things vague in the game Left room to
use your imagination I'm actually really
excited for them to expand upon the
world a bit more and allow us to grow
closer to these characters and it'll be
super interesting to see how the
outbreak plays out in other parts of the
world too so let's talk about the
outbreak the infection in question is
known as the cordyceps brain infection
or CBI which comes from the cordyceps
fungus infecting humans brains causing
them to become hyper aggressive and lose
rational thought as well as mutating
their bodies with fungal growth if
you're not eating a newspaper you can
read at the beginning of the game
indicates that the offending mutated
strain of the cordyceps fungus
originated from contaminated crops
imported from South America and although
the FDA attempted recalling imported
crops from several suspect countries a
few months later roughly 60 percent of
the world's population was either dead
or infected that's why I always say
don't eat your veggies kids today's
video is sponsored by Wonder I'm not an
artist so normally when I think of
something I want to see like giant
fungus monsters mushroom zombie or no
cuddly Mushroom Man I have to rely on a
show like The Last of Us to make it
happen but with wonder I don't have to
rely on anybody else to make my dreams a
reality Wonder turns ordinary text
prompts into incredible pieces of art
using Cutting Edge AI like having an
assistant who's a phenomenal artist that
lives to create the stuff you want to
see I have spent hours and hours
building up a library of mushroom
zombies doing things Joel and Ellie dare
not dream of using wonder and now I get
to share these images with my friends
it's great wonder is a free download but
if you upgrade to premium you'll have no
ads unlimited art faster load times and
over 20 additional Styles you can use
click the link in the description box to
get started with Wonder and put your
creativity to the test twenty years
later we can learn more about CBI from
an in-game pamphlet and infographic from
the federal Disaster Response agency or
fedra which replaced the United States
government as the nation's leading
Authority after the outbreak in the game
CBI in the present day is transmitted
via breathing in the 4 is emitted by the
cordyceps or via contact with bodily
fluids of an infected individual usually
by being bitten however they decided
against using spores in the show due to
the unrealistic nature of keeping an
Airborne contagion confined to small
areas like in the game instead replacing
them with tendrils on the infected's
bodies this is actually not too far of a
departure from The Source material as
concept art for the game showed
illustrations of some Infected having
tendrils and truckman liked the idea of
having the infected being able to
interconnect like networks of fungi to
unite against prey as one but if you get
bitten or potentially stung maybe good
luck because there's no cure as all
attempts to make a vaccination have
failed and there's no way to lengthen
the incubation period and just to put a
cherry on this delicious fungus pie the
cordyceps fungus does in fact exist in
the real world infecting carpenter ants
and compelling them to leave their nest
to find an ideal climate for the fungi's
growth and die there so the fungus can
grow out of them but luckily in the real
world it only affects ants for now in
the game there are four stages of
infection stage one begins within two
days of infection when the cordyceps has
taken over the victim's motor functions
known as Runners they are fast and agile
and travel in packs stage two can
develop anywhere within a year of
infection when the infection has
completely taken over the brain and
begins to develop outward fungal growths
on the head and spread to other parts of
the body as well known as stalkers their
senses are still intact so they maintain
the sight and Agility of Runners but
actually strategize by hiding to Ambush
victims or flanking and attacking from
behind after a year of infection the
host reaches stage three at this stage
they are known famously as clickers as
the fungal growth has reached a point of
blinding them making them reliant on
their use of echolocation paired with
their acute hearing they are stronger
more vicious and extremely lethal if an
infected host is able to remain alive
for several several years which is rare
they can reach the fourth stage known as
bloaters covered in hardened fungal
plates that act as armor these infected
are extremely strong and can throw
acidic balls of spores tone from their
own bodies there's also a type of infect
did called shamblers but it's unknown
whether this is a fifth stage or a
variation of the fourth stage that's
dependent on if they're exposed to large
amounts of water and or humidity anyway
they grab onto prey and expel us it
explores that burn the victim now it's
been revealed that there will be some
Infected individuals that are unique to
the show but Naughty Dog the studio
Behind The Last of Us game had concept
artists work with the show's team to
make sure everything coherently fit
together and I cannot wait to see what
these new designs will look like so like
I said most of the story takes place 20
years after the initial CBI outbreak
which in the game is 2033 since the
outbreak started in 2013 but promotional
materials for the show place the
outbreak in 2003 meaning that this will
set the show truly in the current day
that's fun now allow me to describe this
hellscape the collapse of the economic
and political pillars of society due to
the outbreak has given rise to
military-run quarantine zones in cities
across the U.S remember bedrid yeah they
declared martial law and now exercise
absolute law over the quarantine zones
whoops survivors who seek refuge in
these quarantine zones are reliant on
rations which are frequently lacking or
withheld and poor conditions lead to
unrest Rebellion smuggling and even
groups set on Uprising against the
militia the biggest of which is the
group known as the fireflies the
fireflies are a rebel group set on
taking down Phedra to restore the
government and also working to find a
cure for CBI while some citizens of the
quarantine Zone stand with them
especially when members are publicly
executed by militia others criticize
their lack of pulling their own or fear
the potential of the fireflies replacing
fedra so support for the group is shaky
while life's tough inside the quarantine
zones it's no picnic outside of them
either individuals and groups who travel
or live outside the zones also have to
survive a different type of environment
one overgrown by nature and filled with
constant threat from both the infected
and fellow humans doing anything to
survive with life being as tough as it
is with the state of the world Humanity
has developed a dog eat dog mindset that
leads to some major conflicts when
people cross paths in competition for
food supplies and land it's hard to tell
who to trust in an environment where
bands of ravagers and families just
trying to get by can be
indistinguishable or even one in the
same so that is the brutal environment
we're likely dealing with in the show
but who is the show about I want to
lightly touch on some of the people
we'll be introduced to in the beginning
of the show and again don't worry there
will be no big spoilers everything
mentioned here is either in the show's
trailer or some of the first vague
information we get in the game so the
first three characters were introduced
to are Joel Sarah and Tommy Sarah is
Joel's thoughtful daughter who has an
upbeat personality and playful sense of
humor and Tommy is Joel's brother a
rugged yet compassionate man who's close
with a pair now Joel is our main
character and he's a man whose hard past
has made him develop a callous and
cynical nature and while in the game
Joel is incredibly resilient and
extremely agile in the show Maze and
wanted Joel's character should be less
bulletproof both physically and
metaphorically stating he likes his
middle-aged people to be middle-aged
thus introducing to the character
ailments like hearing damage from
gunfire and knees that ache when he
stands up and I think this will help the
character feel more vulnerable after all
in a video game you can take eight
bullets to the face and be a okay and
even if you die you just respawn but a
TV show needs to add real risk to all
the characters actions in order to get
the viewer invested so I think having
him be more susceptible to Danger gives
his moments a badassery more weight it's
a word look it up meme Webster
dictionary better post outbreak were
introduced to Tess Joel's longtime
smuggling partner who works with him to
get weapon supplies and other Contraband
in and out of a quarantine Zone in
Boston Tess is an independent Street
Smart Survivor who is respected by those
that know her as well as Joel's closest
Ally in Confidant the game keeps their
exact relationship description close to
the chest and we'll have to wait and see
if the show does this as well while on a
job Joel and Tess meet Marlene who is
the courageous strong-willed leader of
the fireflies played by Merle Dandridge
who's the same actress who voiced and
provided the motion capture performance
for the character in the game this is
the only performer from the game who is
reprising their role and she's expressed
in interviews how excited she was to get
to explore the character's complexities
again saying that over the course of 10
years between the game and the show she
has gotten an opportunity to mature as
an artist mature into the role and
really get to know her on a deeper more
inherent level I personally am so pumped
to see what she adds to the performance
this time around and it is Marlene who
assigns Joel and Tess the task of
transporting our other Central character
Ellie to the Capitol Building Ellie is a
blunt impulsive 14 year old who still
manages to hold on to Hope despite the
bleakness of the world around her clever
and resourceful she's insistent that she
doesn't need to be babysat one thing
that makes Ali one of my favorite
characters is her sense of humor which I
think Bella Ramsay will absolutely nail
while there's a lot of mystery
surrounding her character as we see in
the trailer it is her potential immunity
to CBI that launches the expedition to
escort her West where Akira is being
worked on and while that's our main cast
of characters there are so many more
juicy characters and story lines and
druckman teased that along the journey
our protagonists will be meeting new
characters in situations unique to the
show that are self-contained and
promised to pack a punch so now that
I've set the scene I'm gonna sell the
crap out of it I'm gonna talk to those
who haven't seen or played the game
first The Last of Us is known for having
one of the greatest stories in video
game history there's a reason they're
making it into a TV show instead of one
of the other zillions of games out there
this story explores themes of lost
Humanity purpose loyalty perseverance
self-preservation family nature survival
and so much more if you think this is
just going to be another zombie show nah
man it examines deeper Concepts like the
flourishing of nature without human
interruption or as druckman says the
beautiful and horrible things that can
come out of a parent's unconditional
love for their child speaking of the
flourishing of nature this show is also
going to be beautiful one of the coolest
aspects of this game is the design of
the world outside of the quarantine
zones where Nature has reclaimed
abandoned cities with buildings that are
overgrown with plants and animals free
to explore previously unoccupied spaces
inspired by the world without us a book
which speculates how the world would be
affected if humans suddenly disappeared
it also reminds me of the articles that
were coming out in the real world about
wild animals venturing into cities while
everyone was quarantining in 2020. in
the game as much as the outside world
poses a threat its stark contrast
against the quarantine Zone's bleakness
is breathtaking there's Beauty in the
brutality which which is even extended
to the infected in an early version of
the script when referring to an infected
host Mason wrote he lifts his head The
Sun Shines warmth on his face he rises
slightly toward it a soft Breeze
flutters through his hair this is a
living creature in a living world I mean
how am I supposed to refer to them as
enemies with a description like that
maybe you may want to put a ring on its
finger but seriously it goes to show
that everything is being treated with
such respect in this world and I love
that on that same note the story also
features notable minority representation
and strong and capable female character
representation which are always pluses
in my book now for those who have played
the game and are worried that the show
won't be able to replicate it well first
of all it won't but that's a good thing
there's no reason to create a perfect
replica of the game you could just go
watch a playthrough on YouTube for that
but this adaptation is in the best hands
it could possibly be in the creator of
the game and story is making this show
and he's handling it with such care in
fact in 2014 druckman was offered the
chance to make a film version of The
Last of Us but feared that the story
couldn't properly be told in a movie
length feature and had a different
Creative Vision from the executives who
were pushing for something more
action-packed like World War Z when he
wanted something with more heart that
focused on the relationship of the
characters citing influences like
children of men and the novel city of
Thieves it wasn't until he met up with
Craig Mason that he felt the story could
be done Justice Mason knew The Last of
Us extremely well and agreed that the
story would be better told through a TV
series and Mason had already made
Chernobyl for HBO which had won 10 Emmys
and excelled at portraying complex
characters and making grisly moments
impactful druckman even said that in
their pitch meeting for the show Mason
pitched it with such a passion that
druckman was newly moved by the story
that he himself created both of them
knew that to make the most impactful
piece of art possible they wanted to
focus on the relationship aspects of the
story rather than the action and when
there was action they wanted each death
to hold weight unlike in the game where
you can mow down 50 people in one area
and just go about your day and if you're
more interested in the action-packed
part of it don't worry it'll still have
plenty of survival horror elements with
a budget higher than the first five
seasons of Game of Thrones to bring all
those lovely infected to life so we have
a show set in an astonishing world with
deep complex characters and a story with
an incredible amount of heart made by
people who cherish it what more could
you ask for Mason had a quote about the
show that I really loved it's that it
examines the people who want to make
everybody better and the people who want
to protect particular people at any cost
Shivers so I will definitely be tuning
into episode one and if you're joining
me in this journey be sure to follow
along as we break down each episode
every week until then you can follow me
on Twitter at it's annavanston and
follow And subscribe to new rockstars at
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love and I promise not to
show you that gross clip of the antigon
think
ing
[Music]
[Music]